we've got a voicemail number two one
nine to david p this is kind of funny
this is related to iran the libertarian
hero okay take a listen to this hi david
and producer pat this is Randall and
Buffalo and I have a question to put
forward to you I have no knowledge and
skill or training by the way to be able
to answer this question myself okay
so I'm putting it to you is it possible
that iron Rand when she wrote her
material was being satirical or was that
it was intended to be a parody or
rationality cynical
it just seems almost to me like it was
satire but I people on the right taking
it seriously and given it a life of its
own that maybe she didn't intend I don't
know she actually believed those things
that she said and she herself was on
public assistance at one point right
anyway I'd love to hear your thoughts on
that is it at all possible
has anyone ever given this idea some
sort of investigation thank you when I
heard this voice mail
I thought of l ron Hubbard which is is
it not possible that all of l ron
hubbard scientology writing was also
either satire or just sci-fi that he
came up with and then realized he could
make money off of it i don't know much
about ein rand yeah i don't believe that
she was writing her book satirically but
it's actually the most generous
explanation because to write that
nonsense as satire is one thing to write
it as real is much much more disturbing
but i don't think that i don't have no
reason to believe that's the case yeah
and I haven't read Atlas Shrugged or any
other area ed yeah I I just hear that
they're pretty poor when it comes to the
narrative that's why the ideology behind
it and that's what you're really
supposed to cut at but it just doesn't
interest me that much I read a chapter
like in each The Fountainhead and Atlas
Shrugged and I found myself completely
uninterested by it and I just left it
but the writing was not excellent it
really wasn't you always see some guy in
the subway reading one of her books
oh I've not noticed that or maybe like a
sophomore in high school who's just kind
of
disgruntled and part of the
counterculture yeah right or actually
there used there's a talk radio
conference I used to go to where I met
Janki ogre for the first time and there
used to be a publisher who just
specialized in einer and not a books and
would sell them at the talk radio
conference I don't know why they were
there I guess a lot of libertarians in
radio who knows we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today david
pakman.com slash membership patreon.com
slash david pakman show will speak to
you then